of you have had questions about the
school year so we have been collecting
them
and wanted to take them directly to the
people in charge
joining us now is dr carla lauria who is
the chief academic officer at ccsd thank
you so much for your time this evening
we greatly appreciate that doctor
we do have several questions from our
viewers so let's begin with the first
teresa roach mchugh she wants to know
what is the district going to do about
the magnet programs
she says her daughter is in her senior
year at northwest and it's a very
hands-on program
thank you for having us and for allowing
to answer some of these questions that
are so important for so many of our
parents
distance education of course is not
ideal but is needed
during the current pandemic so for
magnet programs all
we understand that they are hands-on and
in many cases it is important for the
kids to be in school
but our students will have the
opportunity to engage
with the teachers virtually our teachers
are finding
great ways to do the best
they can to reach out to the students um
allow them to participate in activities
in on
online activities that are engaging we
do know that
distance education is not ideal we want
students back in school but when it's
needed with
a pandemic our trustees are receiving
updated health information every 30 days
they will be determining um
based on the information we we receive
uh when
is a good time for all of us to be to go
back to platform
um of course keeping safety in the form
in the forefront
dr our next question comes in from a
viewer named kelsey chatwin
she writes in what are the schedules
going to look like for preschool and
kids with ieps
will students who need help with speech
still get to see a speech teacher
um yes the schedules for preschool will
look similar to
their kindergarten schedules they will
follow the normal schedule or during
that normal hours
if their child is in half day preschool
it's going to be of course a shortened
day if it's in a full day preschool
the student will have opportunities to
engage
in two ways with the teachers one of
them is the
synchronous way we have heard that word
um
more often lately than ever but that
really means
um to be able to participate in a
face-to-face
activity with the teacher in a live
activity with the teacher
virtually so it is just like we are
doing right now
uh via the technology then we are going
to be able to access the teacher
directly
and also we will be able to to
learn via asynchronous
model lessons which really means
uh students engage in in their own
learning independently with
activities that have been specially
selected by the teachers to continue the
learning of the students
students with ieps students like you
said who may need speech they will be
able
to connect virtually with the teachers
at this point um the teachers will need
to use their discretion and determine
whether they feel comfortable to come
into the school
whether they feel safe to come into the
school
and um either work at the school
or from the school or work virtually but
they will be able to engage
in um in the special needs
opportunities that they may have based
on their ieps
okay dr lorea mandy mccabe wants to know
the following she wants to know if there
will be any additional tutoring services
available yes there will be additional
tutoring services
student services have uh have always
been managed at the school level
and there will be opportunities for
students to engage
in smarter group or one-on-one sessions
virtually
with their teachers as the teachers feel
the need
we're also as a district working with
different organizations
um to organize probably
community organizations who may be also
available
to provide services to students and if
they feel comfortable then maybe
students may be able to attend those
sessions
face to face dr lorea this question
comes in from scott r
joseph he writes in what is going to
happen with the credits towards
graduation
um as usual there are there are online
credit recruitable options for students
we also have the nevada learning academy
and that will be functioning as normal
they have always been
virtual so that will continue our
students also
will have the ability to graduate early
from high school
uh if they have the credits that make
them eligible to do that
at the same time educators will be able
to reach out students
in very unique way in very
individualized manners so that they can
support students
to recover credits if that is the case
but students will continue
being able to recover credit towards
graduating
dr carla lorea joining us live on eight
news now doctor we thank you so much for
your time in providing that information
for our viewers we do appreciate it
thank you